retour station auber en apéro un peu de
promo en attendant le best au blind test
bonjour louis aubert oui certes et leur
diplôme
tu es là pour ton nouveau disque qui
s'appelle de bleu blanc vert
c'est exact parce que comme tu l'as si
bien dit pour le bicentenaire on aurait
pu en profiter pour changer la couleur
du drapeau vert est là oui parce qu'un
sang impur
qu'un sang impur abreuve nos sillons max
c'est une phrase iranienne ouais mais
quand même il ya quelque chose c'est
normal qu'on prête c'est les droits de
bob wilson stobart
mais sinon le rouge du drapeau je n'aime
pas en plus il est censé représenter la
fraternité autant prendre le verre ou le
bleu tu sais pourquoi est ce que ça
signifie donc drapeau français relève
avec les il a conduit à prévoir pour moi
voulait le bleu blanc vert c'est les
couleurs de la terre vrai que j'ai pas
de faire un historique mais 18 sur te
connaissant que ça rapport avec leur
voile blanc sel blanc le roi dont le
bleu c'est paris c'est ça alors le versé
pour l'écologie donc on peut pas dire
que tu es franchement à rebrousse poil
de l'air du temps quand même non alain
tout mais ce qui va se passer c'est moi
je parle au niveau individuel je suis
pas comme les égaux les écologistes qui
parle
ça c'est très bien aussi certainement
mais je pense que ce mouvement est là
pour durer puisque si du repas on est
mal donc mais l'album c'est pas ça
uniquement si on en retient que ça c'est
déjà pas mal mais c'est vraiment été
décidée par faire des choses concrètes
pour l'écologie avec nous non pas du
tout mais c'est des couleurs de la terre
me plaisait bien pour l'album j'ai eu
beaucoup d'albums aux couleurs de la
ville
hélas cette fois-ci survie je change un
peu d'optique bien j'ai toujours eu ce
côté campeurs vient ici à pleuvoir ouais
ouais ouais ouais je peux le dire
hi fi des temps modernes pacte obama non
c'est pas backs et avançons vers ça
ouais avançant versa couvrons la vie
d'un côté un peu plus calme un peu plus
tribu puis une façon il va bien falloir
meubler ce temps quand on va arrêter un
peu de consommer on va freiner ainsi on
veut protéger tout ça on est obligé de
freiner riposte perron et tous n'ont pas
300 0 croissance 3 4 a besoin
non or avant non il faudrait he may
solution c'est aucune retenue dans le
nécessaire
et puis supprimer le super et le sucre
sauf bon alors là tu sens qu'il est
parti seul alors tu sors qu'on dise que
sous le nom de jean louis aubert c'est
maintenant enhco de l'air donc d'abord
téléphone hier emmanuel cauchy de l'air
regardez tout ce sera aubert online
s'est ouvert ses os est aubert mais ça
c'est décision du nco si on
on a trouvé que c'était pas spécialement
valorisant pour le amicaux se faire
appeler and co ouais et que tant qu'à
faire il a rien dit là qu un os qu il a
il a même proposé et les autres si donc
en fait la même base que plâtre et simon
- le groupe a pas changé donc on a
dissous son champ damit au monde
puisqu'on ne change pas de groupes
autant changer de nom peut utiliser le
studio comme un instrument c'est ce que
tu as dit c'est à dire que tu as
produits toi même plus avec un ingé son
kit a été recommandé par les rites à
sakai effet l'article
l'album des rita c'est ça qui a mixé une
partie des il ya plein de gens
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas les rites assure
se disent non enfin c'est vrai que ça
fait un groupe avec le nom ouais il
valait hier les traveling wilburys ce
français ce qui s'est passé récemment
c'est qu'on s'est vus
des nuits entières et qu'on est qu on a
joué ensemble car avec axel
mon catherine attendait un heureux
événement il y avait une attente et
c'est exact dit non quand les téléphones
tu vends des 600 milles 3 quand tu fais
à nico yvan 120 milles alors là tout
seul tu penses que tu veux rendre
convient par exemple essaye de faire une
déduction mathématiques simples à bord
avec un ou quand j'ai vendu un peu plus
de 100 ans et demi ouais mais je pense
que ce que je vais m'installer je suis
là pour rester ouais on est sur des
biens attention ça me plaît avec le
format n'aura goûté à urville suis
maintenant il faut vite prendre l'habit
liste parce que tu étais parti pour
faire un simple about et sap a coûté
très bon non tu leur as a pas coûté le
prix d'un double album du tout
la preuve c'est que je peux m'imposer
que ce sera plein central c'est moins de
sens vous regardez dans les magasins
c'est le prix d'un simple album c'est
pas un double album d'ailleurs j'ai
rempli le compact disc à ras bord j'ai
quand même jetés dès maintenant mais il
est très bien c'est si tu prend une
dimension non sérieusement quand est ce
que je t'ai dit avoir lundi que c'était
très bien
d'abord le sang et elle ressemble le
plus au son de la bande son vrai nom ils
évoluent là il n'aime pas les quelques
manches et son rip alors pourquoi avoir
voyez vous foutez de ma gueule pour le
son c'est vrai que c'est vrai que et
j'ai vraiment aussi eu le loisir de
profiter des gens qui étaient avec moi
vraiment ya pas eu de deux jeunes
wright a permis à rennes parce qu'en
fait qu'est-ce que je trouvais ces
produits sont aussi c'est comme des
papas c'est à dire c'était beaucoup des
mecs tu pouvais passer tes nerfs dessus
par exemple exactement où leur répéter
cent mille fois par jour tu es sûr de
ses biens et alors donc je me suis dit
ça s'arrête nombreux problèmes et une
fois que j'ai bien vu qui avait personne
je me suis responsabilisé c'est exact
mais lente et père de famille et et je
me suis découvert des toiles et la
qualité qui ne sait pas quand a dit le
travaille en fait dans mon boulot
le vrai travail c'est surtout la promo
parce que ça compte mon âme est pas bien
là ça va à